[Musique]
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est un habitat
c'est un habitat pour qui un bébé
chevreuil il dort ici derrière les
rochers ça le protège des chasseurs très
bonne
[Musique]
idée Elena ericon que faitesv dans ma
maison qui passe votre pèrecob qu
remonte V dernière conversation tout
juste 10 ans je es un peu perdu tes
parents sont pas morts dans un accident
c'est ce que je t'ai
raconté c'est le roi des maraes le type
qui vient de s'échapper lui et un autre
détenu se sont évadés hier
soir jacobbrook surnommé le roi des
marais a enlevé B Ericson et la détenu
pendant 12 ans au fin fond de la forêt
avec sa fille dont elle a accouché en
captivité je voulez pas m'introduire sur
votre terraineneznous je vous en
supplie
père j'ai l'impression qu'il est ici
[Musique]
Clark j'aurais aimé que tu me dises la
vérité ça il me l'a fait quand j'ai tué
mon premier
ser ça ce sont les seules larmes que mon
père supportait de voir mais tu seras
toujours ma petite ombre tout le monde
me dit que la personne en qui je croyais
le plus était en fait un monstre ça veut
dire qu'on est une famille ça veut dire
esclave et non famille ne confonds pas
les deux
Elena qu'est-ce qui se passe il est
revenu je le
sensce que l'habitat est toujours resté
dans ta
chambre tu dois toujours protéger ta
[Musique]
famillea c'est
moi tu sais bien notre place est
ici attendu toute ma vie de te revoir je
savais pas ce que je ressentirais en te
[Musique]
voyant on va de nouveau former une
famille